[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo pendant 26
minutes nous allons faire un tour
d'horizon de l'actualité de la semaine
dans le département
au sommaire de cette édition dernier
conseil d'agglomération avant les
vacances les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines ont débattu notamment sur les
lignes ski bus la thématique des
transports abordé aussi dans le cadre du
projet de territoire le récit de la
soirée dans cette édition une nouvelle
dynamique pour la fusion yvelines
hauts-de-seine
les deux départements notamment annoncé
ce jeudi la mutualisation des services
de gestion des collèges
nous avons fait un point sur le
rapprochement entre les deux
collectivités avec pierre bédier
entretien à suivre enfin dans le reste
de l'actualité nous reviendrons sur
l'installation des panneaux pour la
limitation à 80 km heure puis sur le
lancement des soldes d'été
on commence avec la météo estivale de ce
week end
les maximales dépasseront les 30 degrés
sur toutes les communes de saint quentin
en yvelines
les températures seront au dessus des 20
degrés durant la nuit de samedi à
dimanche avec cette vague de chaleur
pensez à vous hydrater régulièrement à
rester vigilant par rapport aux
personnes vulnérables et à maintenir
votre maison aux frais en gardant vos
volets fermés
un incendie s'est déclaré à 6h30 ce
vendredi matin dans une entreprise à
plaisir une société spécialisée dans la
production de pièces aéronautiques 3500
m² ont été enflammés sur un total de
7000 m² 127 policiers et 35 véhicules
ont été mobilisés pour éteindre les
flammes
les employés de l'industrie ont été
évacués et les élèves des écoles
alentours ont été confinés écoutez le
lieutenant colonel benoît légier il
était au micro de nicolas kirillovitch
c'est une industrie qui procèdent à des
traitements métaux et de peinture la
partie concernée est un atelier de
peinture qui a brûlé donc en termes de
risque tout risque a été écarté
que ce soit en termes de pollution
atmosphérique ou que ce soit en termes
de pollution des eaux vu que le site est
équipé d'un bassin de rétention
donc là on est simplement en train de
sécuriser maintenant les établissements
afin que l'activité puisse reprendre
dans les meilleurs délais une partie du
bâtiment était préservé par notre action
donc une partie pourrait être encore
utilisé pour l'autre partie
effectivement des travaux importants
seront nécessaires pour une reprise de
l'activité
les élus saint quentinois se sont réunis
ce jeudi soir pour la dernière fois
avant les congés estivaux
au programme de la discussion le projet
de territoire le budget et les
transports résumé des échanges avec
wilfrid richie et michael l'hydro des
débats autour de la question des
transports notamment lors de ce dernier
conseil d'agglomération avant les
vacances la délibération portant sur le
projet de report de plusieurs lignes
d'autocars a été l'occasion d'aborder la
stratégie globale de couverture du
territoire avec des points de vue
différents sur les lignes les moins
fréquentées
l'appréciation de l'organisation de
transports depuis longtemps et faites de
manière trop technocratique par la
région que ce soit ile-de-france
mobilité ou avant le stif un peu importe
par l'autorité que responsable des
transports une autorité organisatrice de
transport
elle doit se préoccuper de la desserte
de tous les quartiers partout et même et
quand il ya une faible fréquentation
d'une ligne qui existent elles existent
on doit s'en préoccuper
quand il y a
dix fois plus de personnes sur un site
bah oui et qui a moins de trente
personnes sur un autre trajet oui on
diminue le nombre de deux
de passage sur le site houiller 30
personnes et on va l'augmenter par jour
maginez et on l'augmenté bien sûr sur là
où il ya plus de 1000 personnes bien sûr
pour donner plus
1 un espace où il ya plus d'activité ben
oui il faut enlever ailleurs parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en a pas on doit
travailler à l'intérieur d'un cercle
fermé de financièrement on a pu ces
pilotes en époque
concrètement dès le mois de septembre
cette course par jour seront ajoutées
sur la ligne 475,6 pour la ligne 39 12
plus globalement la question des
déplacements sera étudiée dans le cadre
du projet de territoire un projet en
partie présenté lors de cette même
séance et qui entend établir deux
priorités emploi et économie de demain
et dynamisation du cadre de vie de ce
conseil d'agglomération l'on retiendra
aussi que le déficit de l'île de loisirs
reculent grâce à une diversité des
activités sur le site -6% par rapport à
2016 il s'établit à 836 1000 euros pris
en charge par l'agglomération et le
département on a été élu pour pour
diminuer la dette pour pour équilibrer
les comptes
en même temps et en même temps on peut
améliorer la qualité se vend toujours
faire mieux avec moins
une autre bonne nouvelle après l'annoncé
par standard and poor's de l'attribution
de la note aa - à la gestion de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est l'acte 2 de coopération entre les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine les deux
présidents des collectivités patrick
devedjian et pierre bédier ont annoncé
ce jeudi à nanterre la mutualisation de
la gestion des collèges ainsi que la
mise en place d'un service
interdépartemental de la commande
publique une nouvelle dynamique dans la
fusion des deux départements c'est la
thématique que nous avons abordé avec
pierre bédier un entretien réalisé ce
jeudi 28 juin regardez pierre bédier
bonjour je rappelle que vous êtes
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines et vice président de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental entre les
hauts-de-seine et les yvelines alors
cette fusion entre les hauts-de-seine et
yvelines se poursuit notamment vous
l'avait annoncé ce jeudi 28 juin
l'unification des services de gestion
des collèges alors comment ça va se
faire concrètement et à partir de quand
comme pour les routes puisqu'il y a un
an c'est la gestion des routes que nous
avions mis en commun comme nous avons
des principes de gestion similaire et
bien progressivement les équipes vont se
rejoindre donc avec des hiérarchies
commune bien entendu il n'y aura pas de
fermeture du collège bien entendu il n'y
aura pas moins d'effectifs dans les
collèges cette administration centrale
ce qu'on appelle l'administration
centrale que la convergence se fera nous
avons un peu plus de collégiens dans les
yvelines que dans que dans les
hauts-de-seine où nous en avons dix
mille de plus mais nous pensons là aussi
que le rassemblement de c2c direction
pourra nous permettre de faire mieux
avec moins
c'est ça l'objectif c'est réaliser des
économies ça n'est pas que ça j'ai bien
dit de faire mieux avec moins
c'est à dire moins ce sont les économies
mais mieux c'est une qualité de service
public supplémentaire l'autre point que
vous avez dont vous avez parlé
ce jeudi c'est activity qui est un
modèle pour les autres c'est donc les
yvelines sont une source d'inspiration
pour les hauts-de-seine mais c'est aussi
des hauts-de-seine qui sont une source
d'inspiration pour les yvelines
notamment pour se passe pour les
collégiens et favoriser le développement
de la culture et de la pratique sportive
c'est ça exactement dans cette
dans ce rassemblement nos deux
départements c'est bien entendu ce qu'on
appelle d'un terme peu barbare la
rationalisation mais c'est aussi de la
stimulation comme on a dépassé différent
des actions différentes et bien les
équipes confrontent leurs confondent
pacifiquement bien entendu créativement
leurs expériences et on essaye de
prendre le meilleur c'est le mieux dont
je parlais tout à l'heure avec le moins
on essaye de prendre des expériences des
autres et c'est vrai que les
hauts-de-seine sont en avance sur les
yvelines avec ce pass éducation adressé
aux collégiens et je pense que ça sa
généralisation aux territoires yvelinois
sera une bonne chose pour les collégiens
et pour leurs familles alors c'est un
dispositif vous l'avez dit qu'on ne
connaît pas dans les yvelines
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
pour les collégiens yvelinois ils auront
un pass qui représente une valeur de 81
euros et qui leur permet qui d'aller au
spectacle qui d'aller adhérer à une
association sportive
c'est donc une aide qui est apportée aux
familles tout naturellement un certain
nombre de conditions mais je pense que
c'est aussi une façon d'aider à
l'apprentissage de la vie ça fait un peu
partie de nos missions jeudi un peu
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un des
paradoxes on confie les collèges vont
nous confie pas tout à fait les
collégiens c'est pourquoi le département
ne faisait pas ça mais on a vu avec
l'expérience alto séquanaise que ça
marchait donc on a décidé de faire comme
eux alors l'année dernière vous
souhaitiez créer une nouvelle
collectivité issue de la fusion des deux
départements
le gouvernement nous a pas suivis sur ce
dossier là en transférant plusieurs
compétences départementales je rappelle
que vous êtes à 45% des compétences
départementales unifiée l'objectif pour
vous et patrick devedjian ce n'est pas
d'eux aujourd'hui de rendre effective et
concrète
cette nouvelle collectivité en vidant en
quelque sorte les compétences des deux
départements séparés et en les unifiant
les unifiant tout d'abord le
gouvernement ne s'est pas opposé le
gouvernement ne nous a pas répondu
donc il n'y ni mot consent d'une
certaine façon
alors on sait qu'ils ne nous répond pas
parce qu'il n'a pas encore arrêté le
périmètre de la métropole mais nous
pensons que puisqu'il y à un consensus
de la gauche de la droite et même d en
marche dont on ne sait pas s'ils sont à
gauche ou à droite
encore que j'ai ma petite idée pour un
périmètre élargi
il n'y a donc pas problème de fond c'est
vrai que si on avait fait la petite
métropole la métropole riquiqui avec
paris et la petite couronne comme nous
on est en grande couronne et les
hauts-de-seine en petite couronne sur un
problème de frontière
mais le gouvernement m'a l'air de
comprendre qu'on ne peut pas que depuis
1989 le mur est tombé et gros construire
des murs artificiels n'est pas n'est pas
une bonne idée donc je pense que on
devrait y arriver il faudrait un peu de
temps bien entendu et nous oui nous
considérons que puisque nous améliorons
la vie de nos concitoyens
puisque nous sommes avec l'état
détenteur de l'intérêt général il nous
faut avancer et c'est vrai qu'après ça
sera compliqué de distinguer l'un de
l'autre
quand vous avez casser les oeufs dans la
poêle pour faire une omelette c'est
assez difficile de reconstituer les yeux
après qu'est ce qu'on s'est dit emmanuel
macron lors des échanges que vous avez
pu avoir avec lui lors de sa visite dans
les yvelines en février dernier je n'ai
pas dire le secret des conversations que
je peux avoir avec le président de la
république mais ce que j'ai eu le
sentiment de dire
je crois qu'il a entendu ce que j'ai le
sentiment qu'il avait entendu ce que je
voulais lui dire qu'il a sans doute
compris combien c'était complexe et
combien écouter des élus locaux qui ont
l'expérience pouvait être utile parce
que il faut des hauts fonctionnaires
mais dans une démocratie décentralisée
comme la république française il faut
aussi savoir écouter les élus qui font
tourner les machines au service de leurs
concitoyens je reformule ma question
centrale est évidemment le secret de
votre conversation mais quel regard ils
portent sur vos initiatives vous avez
pris avec monsieur devedjian sur cette
fusion des départements on n'a pas
spécialement parlé de cette fusion
puisqu'on a centré notre discours sur la
métropole du en paille parce que je
partage l'ambition du président la
république comme je partageais celle
d'un de ses prédécesseurs nicolas
sarkozy qui a créé cette dynamique du
grand bail il faut une grande métropole
parisienne mais ensuite nous divergeons
sur la façon de la montée sur son
périmètre sur son fonctionnement sur ses
compétences et là croyez moi leurs
écarts que nous avons passées ensemble
n'était pas suffisante pour faire le
tour de la question
or actuellement vous à l'e3 politique
public interdépartemental l'entretien
l'expression de l'exploitation des
routes par dont l'adoption et
l'archéologie préventive
vous avez aussi un aménageur public
commun ce site aliot quel bilan vous
faites deux déjà en sur deux ans de de
cette unification des polices alors
d'abord moi je suis surpris que ça soit
allé aussi vite parce que je trouve que
les équipes se sont bien mêler
et assez rapidement et ensuite nous
atteignons nos objectifs en matière
d'économies sur la voirie par exemple et
d entretien était de 40 millions et
passe à 36 10 % d'économie ça n'est pas
rien et comme nous allons élargir
puisque c'est un des objectifs d'avoir
un service de commande publique donc
service achat aussi on était une
entreprise qui soit commun nous allons
continuer naturellement à faire des
économies
pierre bédier rester avec nous on passe
au résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
près de 600 kilomètres de routes vont
être limités à 80 km/heure dans les
yvelines
une mesure qui rentre en vigueur ce
dimanche 1er juillet dans le département
les équipes se sont préparées pour cette
nouvelle mesure un reportage de nicolas
kirilow beats
2 90 à 80 km/heure le changement s'opère
seulement quelques secondes pour ces
agents de la voirie
donc on fait faut juste de dévisser au
niveau des brides donc à quatre vis à
desserrer et remettra iv vi pour
remettre le 80 donc c'est assez rapide
comme comme opération une opération
rapide en bord de route il y a une
dizaine de panneaux a changé dans ce
secteur cent cinq au total dans le
département des yvelines
d'ici le 1er juillet près de 600
kilomètres de routes passeront à 80
km/heure une mesure pour la sécurité
routière pour le gouvernement qui espère
sauver 300 à 400 vies par an mais une
mesure qui fait débat auprès de
l'opinion dans la vallée de chevreuse
connu pour ses routes accidentées comme
la départementale 906 l'abaissement de
la vitesse c'est diversement accueillie
par les habitants des zones dangereuses
que 80 c'est très bien et d'autres 90
bon effectivement maintenant ça dépend
du civisme chacun respecte ne respecte
pas et je crois que c'est une vraie
mesure c'est mathématique ça ne se
défend pas donc tout à fait pour pour
chevreuse et les alentours wee cc c'est
bien mais
moi je pense que oui c'est un peu quand
même exagéré pour ces deux là comme
c'est pour nous pomper encore du fric
comme d'habitude la crainte des amendes
et des flashs principaux arguments
avancés par les opposants à cette
réduction de la vitesse
les gendarmes se veulent pourtant
rassurants dans un premier temps ils
promettent d'être clément avec les
contrevenants ce que nous allons faire
c'est accompagner le changement de cette
nombre et je vais demander aux gendarmes
je sais que tu as routière des yvelines
de faire preuve de pédagogie pour
expliquer les raisons de son changement
le 1er juillet les jours qui suivront
nous serons sur les routes a réalisé des
contrôles routiers
mais le seront prioritairement axé sur
le contrôle des grands excès de vitesse
n'est plus dangereux c'est bien ça notre
mission en 2017 dans les yvelines 48
personnes sont décédées sur les routes
du département 17 d'entre elles sur les
axes concernés par la réforme alors
pierre bédier comment vous vous êtes
préparez vous à ce changement comment le
département s'est préparé à ce
changement avec l'arrivée des 80 km 1
je n'ai jamais caché mon hostilité à
cette mesure dont l'utilité pour moi
n'est pas fondée je vois bien le coot je
vois bien les ennuis que ça va générer
pour les automobilistes que les amendes
sont une recette maintenant non
négligeable pour pour l'état
bon mais nous sommes républicains donc
ballet service voirie commun d'ailleurs
au département des hauts-de-seine et des
yvelines fonds nécessaires et sur tous
les tronçons biz et nous serons avec des
panneaux 80 km heure vous avez travaillé
avec la préfecture
est ce que vous êtes sentis écoutés par
l'état si je vous répondais non vous
n'en seriez pas surpris parce que c'est
comme d'habitude
un dernier point le bureau à y avait un
bureau extraordinaire ce mardi 26
juillet un bureau extraordinaire de
l'assemblée des départements de france
qui souhaite prendre du recul par
rapport à l'état c'est un divorce entre
les départements et l'état
non c'est plus compliqué sonné une
mission spécifique nous les départements
qui est la mission sociale nous
exécutons pour le compte de l'état des
missions sociales qu'il s'agit du rsa
qu'il s'agisse de la pas qu'il s'agisse
de l'allocation handicapé et chaque
année l'état nous rembourse un peu moins
parce qu'il nous remboursait l'année
d'avant et en plus souvent il ya une
augmentation du nombre d'allocataires
donc on se retrouve avec un effet de
ciseaux absolument délirant pas que nous
essayons de compenser tout en protestant
et maintenant l'état entend ce que nous
comprenons bien limiter les hausses des
dépenses des départements
mais ce sont ses dépenses à lui qui sont
dans nos comptes
donc nous lui disons retirer au moins ça
et puis quand même qu'on pensait loin
peut en particulier les mineurs non
accompagnés
la question migratoire est quand même
brûlante aujourd'hui à l'europe et en
france on a ce problème des mineurs non
accompagnés qui relève de la politique
de l'état
de par leur entrée sur le territoire
mais qui relève en jeu suite au titre de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance des
départements et sans nous ne compense
pas vous avez des départements le
département d'indre-et-loire petit
département certes mais qui a pas de
moins de droits que les autres
départements
les dépenses pour les mineurs non
accompagnés sont désormais
budgétairement supérieures aux dépenses
en faveur des communes comment voulez
vous qu'il n'y ait pas une révolte des
habitants à un moment donné
nous tirons le signal d'alarmé la force
des départements c'est qu'on n'est pas
éloigné de nos concitoyens on sait ce
qu'il pense on sait ce qu'ils ressentent
on connaît leurs souffrances et et donc
nous tirons la le signal d'alarmé ne
divorcent chante pas d'avec l'état nous
lui disons attention casque ou un sujet
qu'il faudra donc suivre dans les
prochains mois l'eau sujet avec beaucoup
d'épisodes et j'espère un happening
comme on dit en bon français
intermedia merci et passer un bon
week-end merci
autre information concernant le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines elle nous vient de nos
confrères du point
la société du grand paris doit désigner
son président du conseil de surveillance
le 17 juillet prochain
car bédié serait candidat à ce poste il
assure avoir le soutien de ses sept
homologues des départements franciliens
mais quatre d'entre eux assurent n'avoir
signé aucun document à cordes or ce
soutien
le principal concerné se défend en
précisant qu'il a eu un accord par
téléphone les soldes d'été sont laissés
de sang sont lancés depuis mercredi dans
toute la france les commerçants
accueille les visiteurs venus profiter
de cette première journée des réductions
prévues jusqu'au 7 août prochain à one
nation paris aux clayes-sous-bois les
premiers clients sont arrivés dès 8
heures deux heures avant l'ouverture
officielle
camille lambert s'est glissé parmi eux
au reportage
à peine arrivé et déjà les premiers
achats jamel est un habitué de cette
enseigne
il est venu dès 8 heures pour profiter
des réductions j'ai pris quelques
articles j'ai pas de budget spécialement
non je viens ici je choisis je regarde
ce qui me plaît puis voilà pour ce
magasin les deux premières semaines de
soldes représentent 30% du chiffre
d'affaires de la saison
un rendez vous immanquable pour lequel
les responsables se prépare on a une
préparation assez dense déjà depuis la
semaine dernière
on a aussi augmenté énormément les
équipes on a quasiment doublé le staff
sur la première semaine parce que c'est
là que tout se joue sur un mercredi
normal on est 4 et là on évite ce
week-end on sera onze ses seules deux
sont les dernières à durer six semaines
dès l'an prochain elles seront à quatre
semaines a one nation paris toutes les
boutiques sont prêtes
le centre commercial outlet a ouvert ses
portes deux heures plus tôt pour
accueillir les visiteurs
je suis venu hier soir et puis j'ai
essayé ce que je voulais prendre et
voilà je suis militante ya pas trop de
monde pour essayer de faire les achats
rapidement si je tombe sur quelque chose
qui me plaît mais sinon j'attends
toujours les milieux des seuls d'un
général les cinq premiers jours de
soldes c'est 30 % de trafic et cheap de
la période des soldes d'été
je sais que le budget un petit peu moins
fort en été puisque les pièces sont un
petit peu plus fine y'a pas les manteaux
etc
mais on est sur des tickets 250 350
euros un panier au dessus de la moyenne
nationale en 2017 les consommateurs
avaient dépensé 200 euros ils ont
jusqu'au 7 août pour finaliser leur
achat pour l'été one nation paris
propose également de nombreuses
activités
après une semaine de fermeture pour
cause de vidange le centre aquatique du
lac à montigny le bretonneux va
effectuer sa réouverture ce samedi matin
l'occasion pendant cette pause de faire
quelques changements de pièces dans la
partie machinerie en début d'année la
piscine avait été fermée durant quatre
semaines pour d'importants travaux
d'entretien changement de sols et de
murs dans les sanitaires ou encore
changement du contrôle d'accès des
travaux qui ont coûté quatre cent mille
euros un montant important mais
nécessaires pour accueillir au mieux les
utilisateurs
écoutez cette interview de l'adjoint aux
sports
on a aujourd'hui un outil qui a bientôt
avoir 16 ans ce qui est
par rapport à l'état aujourd'hui de
notre piscine on est plutôt satisfait
mais ça veut dire que l'on passe aussi
par un entretien permanent de
à la fois extérieur donc ce que voit nos
utilisateurs mais à la fois aussi au
niveau interne donc la partie la partie
et je dirais que sous marine plutôt des
gens ne voient pas forcément fait qui
est très importante et je dirais même
presque le plus important depuis jeudi
le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille la 102e édition du
ville de l'open de france
l'occasion de voir s'affronter le numéro
deux mondiale justin thomass l'espagnol
sergio garcia ou le français alexander
levy le tenant du titre britannique
tommy fleetwood va-t-il conserver son
titre
la réponse ce dimanche en fin d'après
midi et nous sommes à moins de 100 jours
du coup d'envoi de la ryder cup à saint
quentin en yvelines pour acheminer les
deux cent cinquante mille supporters qui
se rendront sur le golf national pendant
la compétition
les organisateurs ont mis en place un
plan transport avec des navettes et des
parcs relais autour du site
un dispositif présenté ce lundi soir aux
habitants à l'école
mansare de guyancourt un reportage de
michael et demi d'euros fermetures de
rues conditions de circulation l'impact
de la ryder cup sur le trafic et la vie
des habitants question ce lundi 25 jours
à l'école mansart de guyancourt pour
assurer le comité d'organisation de
l'épreuve étaient présents pour exposer
le dispositif
il ya bien entendu des inquiétudes
puisque l'inconnu fait peur et tant
qu'on n'est pas informée sur
l'organisation d'un événement on peut
effectivement que avoir quelques
appréhensions et c'est le but de ma
présence ce soir dans cette reine au
public d'apporter des réponses à toutes
les questions posées par les riverains
pour limiter les craintes pour limiter
les fantasmes et que chacun sache
comment sera organisée la ryder cup
et puis en fonction prendre ses
dispositions pour absorber un flux de
250 mille spectateurs du 25 ou 30
septembre prochain d'une navette
routière seront mises en place au départ
de la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
quatre parcs relais seront également
créées pour stationner à versailles
louveciennes horse et toussus-le-noble
pour le staff et les vip la ryder cup ce
n'est pas un événement classique car à
la différence d'un match au stade de
france les infrastructures actuelles du
golf national ne sont pas taillés pour
accueillir soixante mille spectateurs
à la différence d'un stade de france qui
a été conçu avec des infrastructures
routières et de transport collectif
adapté
on doit la de manière temporaire
créer un plan de transport qui
permettent d'acheminer tout le monde
jusqu'au golf national après une heure
de questions réponses avec les
organisateurs premier verdict pour les
50 riverains présents dans la salle ça
nous a permis au moins de savoir
exactement comment l'événement à les ai
roulé ça m'a plutôt rassuré parce que
j'ai vu que le trafic routier devrait
être bien maîtrisée dans les prochaines
semaines d'autres réunions d'information
seront organisées à saint quentin en
yvelines les détails complets sur la
circulation pendant la ryder cup seront
diffusés dans les magazines municipaux à
la rentrée et avant de refermer cette
édition je vous rappelle la météo
estivale de votre week end les maximales
dépasseront les 30 degrés sur toutes les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
avec des températures qui seront au
dessus des 20 degrés durant la nuit de
samedi à dimanche
pensez bien avec cette vague de chaleur
à vous hydrater régulièrement à rester
vigilant par rapport aux personnes
vulnérables et à maintenir votre maison
aux frais en gardant vos volets fermés
c'est la femme de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis pour revoir cette
émission rendez vous sur le site
internet ou sur l'application mobile
télé 78 retour de l'information sur
notre antenne lundi à 18 heures avec le
7-8 journal passer un excellent week-end
[Musique]